we have a message for this nakba day for
this 75 years of occupation we want the
world to know that what is being
perpetrated against the Palestinian
people the oppression the subjugation
the terrible cruelty is not in the name
of our religion you have to stop
treating the Palestinians like they're
animals you say you're the children of
God but you treat the Palestinians like
their rats why aren't these Christian
leaders telling the Jewish sinist this
is ungodly you say you're the chosen
people of God you can't behave like this
this is the de show I love you you're
when I was ready to talk about it I
would only talk to I was explaining how
much respect I have for the Fai of
Islam
the assalam alaykum greetings of peace
my next guest Stanford pass comes from a
Jewish background was born into a Jewish
Family he has a deep understanding in
this area of the world where Jesus peace
be upon him was born and he's connected
to the current events he recently shared
something by a very prominent well-known
Christian we're going to go ahead and
this is a Christian news source we're
going to go ahead and play this video
and then bring him out have have a
discussion on the history current events
and Jesus and much much more the
Israelis are going to obliterate Gaza
and when they obliterate Gaza they will
wipe out 2 million gazan Palestinians
and they don't care I told you the
feeling I had when I met I didn't meet
him he didn't shake my hand I'm standing
next to Netanyahu but I got a good look
at him I saw a man that Absolut cold
cold lifeless eyes lifeless eyes
soulless eyes I saw man could he could
kill 2 million people and then go to
dinner wouldn't bother him at all
because in his mind they're not people
that's right they're you have to
understand Savages they're they're
Savages they're beasts in his mind the
Palestinians are not people so he has no
conscience that would bother him and we
are witnessing in real time Mass
genocide and hardly anybody is saying
anything about it and if you do say
something about it you will be extremely
criticize you may be shut down they'll
have a ceasefire when there's nobody
left in Gaza they will stops shooting
when everybody stops breathing that is
the intention folks total elimination of
the Palestinian people this is genocide
I don't care what you think about the
state of Israel no sane human with a
heart can justify genocide a complete
wipe out of a people Stanford pass peace
be with you asalam alaykum alaykum Salam
brother how have you been
alhamdulillah I'm getting uh getting
older and feeling closer to Allah every
day
by the grace protect you preserve you
you Shar this uh video clip here and
I've been thinking for a long time I've
been thinking we often hear Jesus who we
love is one of the mightiest Messengers
uh that God sent just like Moses Abraham
and the last and final messenger muham
peace and blessed be upon them they came
the same message worship the one Creator
alone not his creation I've been
thinking where are the
Christians those who we have so much in
common with who flaunt Jesus anytime
there's anything goes violent they're
like Jesus turn the other cheek uh
Prince of Peace and this seems to be one
of the few here that we're seeing that
is vocal about it we need more
Christians to step up what inspired you
to share this I did have that on my
Facebook page U the reason I shared it
was I wanted people to understand I'm
not looking to just throw dirt on people
who deserve it but I'm trying to
Enlighten people enough that they can
make an informed choice about their
spiritual path and their future because
this is about this isn't about Pol
politics and life and death we're
talking about souls and we're talking
about not just this life but what comes
next so I want people to understand
what's happening here so they can
differentiate truth from
falsehood he made some very powerful
statements he says he said um no sane
person with a heart
so if you're a Jesus believing person
you believe in Jesus we believe in Jesus
you believe in the god of Jesus the one
who created Jesus you believe in the
Life Hereafter you leav in compassion
love Mercy turning the other cheek I
mean because you see now it's because
you have people out there who are
supporting this this is giving the green
light to a person who from True News I
mean they hit it there on this is like
someone who when he saw saw in his eyes
a soulless cess lifeless person who can
just do something to go ahead and want
to exterminate it a whole people like
this it's out of this
world in this time we know
that all the the the three
major Christianity Judaism and Islam are
going to be splintered into many
different sects and groups and they're
all and many of they're going to be
following Innovation and things that are
not from God and then there's the
straight path and the straight path is
what we seek to follow as Muslims which
is you know forbidding evil and
encouraging good and fixing things with
our hands if we can and if we can't to
talk about it and if we can't do that to
hate it in our heart and to be like we
learn in our Fick of worship in our
understanding of worship that thinking
about it not enough you have to act you
have to do something to try to help in
the so we're commanded to help in the
society if there's something wrong
Muslims are commanded to do this to help
fix
Society now you come from a background
as I open up a Jewish background you
were born into a Jewish Family for our
audience uh who hasn't watched we've had
your story here on the dean show if you
can just bring them up to speed so you
you you were born in a Jewish Family and
how how would you address this myth that
people have that Muslims I mean
obviously you wouldn't have accepted
Islam if you thought Muslims hated you
well I didn't even know any Muslims
until I became one uh almost I didn't
really know any um my parents always
taught me to take each person as an
individual and in my home religion was
all about building character be a mench
be a decent human being and that's to
them to my parents they they were they
didn't know what was going on with the
hidden agenda of zionis M they didn't
know all the the the underside of this
they thought it was like a a Homeland
for the Jews that were persecuted all
over the world that's all they that's
all they knew they didn't know and um I
was raised believing that too um and
then I got I got schooled by
life Wow Let's get into this next clip
this is actually a rabbi who's also
saying not in
Judaism we have a message for this Naka
day for this 75 years of occupation we
want the world to know that what is
being perpetrated against the
Palestinian people the oppression the
subjugation the terrible cruelty is not
in the name of our religion it is not in
the name of the Star of David it is not
in the name of the Jewish people around
the world who are true to the Jewish
religion because we are Jews Jewish and
because we are true to our religion we
are in total opposition to the existence
of the Zionist state of Israel I call it
Zionist state of Israel because it is
Zionist it is not Jewish we want the
world to know that the Zionist movement
is not a Jewish movement it was a
political material movement created by
Heretics and they simply try to
incorporate our religion in order to
intimidate and silence people and call
them anti-semitic if they stand in
opposition but this is patently false
anti-semitic is supporting the state of
Israel it is a cause of exacerbating
anti-Semitism by having this occupation
it is a cause of Bloodshed of the
Palestinians and Jews alike it is the
cause of the oppression of not only the
Muslims and the Christians in Palestine
but of the Jews hundreds of thousands of
Jews stand in Palestine have lived their
prior to the state they have lived and
they're continuing to live till today
and demonstrate daily and get brutally
beaten and arrested this is the sad
story of this terrible neba it is a
tragedy a Calamity and God with his
compassion we hope will see the
suffering and even today the last few
days how you see daily the death and
suffering of the Palestinians and the
attacks at all Zionism not Judaism we
can once again live together in harmony
Jews and Arabs as we've had for all
these hundreds and hundreds of years and
Jews could show their gratitude to the
Arab and Muslim countries for their
embracing Jews and giving them a home
inshah soon in our days so this is a
Jewish rabbi yeah and we're hearing
these terms some people hearing it for
the first time you mentioned the word
Zionism he's also saying that there is
not the same thing Judaism and Zionism
can you you for the since you come from
a Jewish background you have you you Liv
you lived this life there not
understanding and now can you bring us
up to speed what does this mean Zionism
well Judaism is the religion of Moses or
that's what it was called it was they
named it they call the the Ben Israel
the children of Israel practiced Judaism
Judaism was named after Judah which is
the grandson of Abraham um
Zionism is a political agenda
to
um to basically it's a domineering um uh
effort to take Palestine and own it uh
the Rothchild family which owns all the
central banks on Earth and half the
wealth on Earth and they're advisers to
the queen and the king and the pope now
and um they own about
everything they needed a place to
shelter their this is Rothschild's
Homeland this is the country that
Rothchild wanted Theodore Herzel who was
the father of Zionism wanted to go to
Argentina Rothchilds didn't want to go
to Argentina they wanted the
Mediterranean
beachfront and um it fit right in with
the prophecies you see had nothing to do
with Hitler World War II they decided in
1897 at the Zionist Congress in
Switzerland we're taking
Palestine then in 1917 well during when
when World War you want me to just go
yeah World War I came along well the
Jews were having a hard time finding a
home they were getting thrown out of
everywhere they were going because of
this small nucleus of people within the
group that just wanted to own and run
everything um uh and uh what happened
they um they made a deal with Britain to
get the United States into World War I
to help him beat
Germany and they in return they were
given they were granted
Palestine and uh that's how that
happened but but it wasn't to to own it
was if you look at the balfor
Declaration it's an agreement that the
Jews were going to be able to move into
Palestine as
cohabitation and live in peace with the
zionists I mean with the with the
Palestinians to live in peace and
Harmony and everybody would have
religious rights and human rights and
all kinds of Rights and everybody would
get along but this was never the agenda
their agenda was once their foot was in
the door to take the whole place and
that's what was happening steadily from
the time they got in in
1917 until now and it was it's just been
an
ongoing effort to to take the whole
place and to not live in harmony and
peace uh with the if if Israel I if the
if if the Jews that went to Israel the
zionists had kept the bargain of the of
the balfor Declaration the balford
Declaration had been kept we probably
wouldn't be in this situation right now
but the Bal for declaration wasn't worth
the paper was written on because they
never intended to keep the agreement
they only wanted to get in the door
that's all and they got in the
door can I say a little can I say
something real quick right here yeah so
just one point uh so when when you me
don't lose your place so when you
mentioned Judaism so this is what they
coined as the religion of Moses but we
know as Muslims ones who submit their
will of God that's what a Muslim is and
Islam is a way of life that since the
beginning of time since the first man
Adam that concept of submission to the
will of the creator of heavens and earth
was has always been there so those
people who are who are at time of Moses
we would say they were submitters to God
they were Muslim and they were doing
Islam submission to the will of God
Islam is water and all these other
religions are Brands because it's all
about submitting to God it's all it's
about it's the essence of religion is to
submit and obey God and Judaism God
didn't ordain Judaism God did not ordain
Christianity but we know as Muslims
Allah did ordain Islam and perfected it
as the faith of the Believers and so we
we're on it's the straight path it's the
water without the brand
without the flavors without the ethnic
associations all the prophets and
Messengers came for a segment of
humanity except the last one peace be
upon them all Muhammad was sent and his
duty his mission was to bring the Quran
to bring to all
Humanity monotheism not to worship idols
not to you
know and to and that was that's why I
became Muslim because I saw it clear as
day
I after living the life I lived Allah
took me around the block a few times and
I could see it clear as day that Islam
was home for a Believer that's home and
it looks so strange to us because we've
been in the west it's been demonized and
they've been hiding it keeping it under
the rug and turning it and um you know
according to a zig I for can't can't
pronounce his name Z big new brazinski
who was a a national sec security
adviser to presidents he said that the
Muslim terrorist apparatus was created
by the US intelligence as a geopolitical
weapon okay wow all right I want to say
also condolences sincere condolences to
the families of all the Innocents on all
the sides of who who are injured or
passed away that my sincere
condolences um Muhammad had rules of War
peace be upon him many of them were
violated by both sides and um my
condolences thank you thank you for that
um thank you yeah that's very it's very
straightforward in Islam that this is
something Rules of Engagement before the
Geneva Convention it's very
straightforward and clear you don't kill
an old person you don't kill a woman you
don't kill a child you don't hurt a
clergy person you don't destroy a a
house of worship you don't cut a tree
you don't cut a tree you know and it's
like you don't yeah you don't do you
don't you don't do carpet bombing of a
whole neighborhoods you know you don't
do the mowing the lawn as they call it
yeah you know this whole thing started I
mean I lived
through JFK's assassination and I Liv
through 911 and I'm beginning to pick up
on things a little bit intuitively now
yeah and this whole thing started with a
big lie the big lie is that these 5,000
Rockets was a
surprise okay my I believe with
everything in me okay based on my life
experience and my intuition that they
knew this Egypt told them it was coming
and Israel it's way out of character for
Israel to ignore a warning even if
they're having political chaos over
there it's very very hard for me to
swallow that Israel ignored warnings
from Egypt that something big was coming
okay so based on that big Li and I don't
believe like that first tape showed I
don't think Netanyahu cared about
sacrificing some some of his own
citizens to get his mission accomplished
which is to destroy the Palestinians to
it was an EXC just like 911 was a false
flag everybody knows it except the you
know that it wasn't how it how they say
it went down but what it was designed to
do was allow the West to go in and
destroy a bunch of Muslim countries and
murder millions and millions of people
millions of people and this is they're
doing the they're following the same
pattern they're following the same
example it was a false flag event
from but you they use real blood and
real people they use us but it was a
false flag event because it isn't what
they said it was it wasn't a surprise
attack I don't believe it you can't
convince me of
you think this is a pretext for you the
um we hear this term nakba nakba can you
define what is a nakba the nakba was the
was the the tragedy of of when the
Palestinians were slaughtered
indiscriminately and they just were they
were just flattened and wiped out and
caused to move and destroyed and it was
just a massacre it's like what they did
to the Native Americans here in America
they just took their land burnt their
crops made him get on the street and
just start walking get out of here knock
yeah some some are saying here we we'll
play this little clip here uh because
we're hearing some of the politicians
from this side who are mentioning this
can I I wait till John I'll wait okay go
ahead right now one goal nakba a nakba
that will overshadow the nakba of 48
Naka in Gaza and Naka to anyone who
dares to join so we we see some of these
uh people from the um side there on the
far right side they keep mentioning we
see people from the area mentioning
nakba nakba
[Music]
[Applause]
nakba
[Music]
[Applause]
fore
second nakba what is this kind of now a
pretext for this extermination this
Annihilation this genocide I believe
that I believe that they staged this for
exactly that and you know what I just
heard on the way home Eddie I drive to
New York every day I I deliver I'm a
courier and I was coming home and I
heard on the radio that Israel's
planning to start their ground Invasion
maybe even tonight on the Sabbath which
is I don't know why they would do that
break their own Sabbath but they don't
follow the Jewish religion the zionists
don't are you know they don't they don't
Zionism and Judaism are two different
things I don't care what anybody says so
one of the
survivors one of the survivors of the
kibuts massacre she's on Facebook you
can find her just you know
Haggard dark hair very tired looking I
I'll send you the link she said the
Arabs were nice to them but when the
Israeli soldiers when the IDF showed up
at the kibuts they shot everybody they
they sprayed everybody they killed they
killed the kutnik and they killed the
Arabs and they killed hamash they killed
everybody this is from a
Survivor wow she said that okay now I
can't I have inv vetted it but she
didn't look like she was like making it
up and another thing was a doctor I saw
this video and I'm going this is
reminding me of of the Kennedy
assassination and 911 is that facts that
would refute the official story just
kind of disappeared they just kind of
dissolved into the
atmosphere these doctors are in a press
conference it's on video on Facebook and
Tik Tok YouTube everywhere the doctors
at the hospital that was bombed said
that the director of the hospital was in
phone contact with a general of the
Israeli Defense Forces on the phone with
them and said why didn't you answer the
phone he says what in other words the
Israeli Defense Forces said to the
hospital people allegedly we sent two
rocket shells over to you as a warning
why didn't you answer your
telephone they said this to the doctors
on this on this press conference there's
a simple way to check this if it's true
look at the phone records I mean I'm
looking at it like this isn't right this
is so common sense down to earth if they
just check the phone records and they
look to see if there was a conversation
between this doctor and Israel's
military there's evidence you know but
nobody's talking about this stuff just
like when 911 happened there were
eyewitnesses they died they disappeared
they got sick this happened that
happened you know I'm just saying the
big lie you know like you want somebody
to swallow a lie you got to make it big
they said this is going back to Nazi
thinking you got to make it a big lie
and then people will just automatically
swallow it so I think it all goes back
to the fact that they allowed this to
happen because they knew they wanted a
like you say they wanted a justification
to commit the Noba again okay let me get
into this next clip and um I get your
reaction to this okay here in the United
States the Christian Zionist movement
John haggy go down the list of them
Perry Stone Lance wall now Steven Strang
at Charisma you go down the whole list
of Zionist puppets are clapping and
cheering for this atrocity they're
delighted I mean this is just so
incredibly disingenuous on their part
why AR they crying peacemakers why
aren't they calling for peace why aren't
they negotiating why aren't they putting
pressure on Israel you have to stop
treating the Palestinians like they're
animals you say you're the children of
God but you treat the Palestinians like
they're rats why aren't these Christian
leaders telling the Jewish Zionist this
is ungodly you say you're the chosen
people of God you can't behave like this
again these are the uh Christians who
are stepping up and they're calling out
the um the Zionist do you know much
about the Christians who are not even
really following Christianity they
they're also just they call themselves
zionists there's a lot of bid there's a
lot of innovation out there there's what
do he say there's going to be over 70
misguided sects of each religion Judaism
Christianity and Islam this is another
misguided SE another misguided sect this
is also a new movement huh this
Christian Zionism I don't know exactly
when it started but it hasn't been that
long ago m i what 20 years maybe I don't
know just I've been aware of it only
that long but it's very nice to see that
these Christians here uh do you know the
uh the person's name some of these
Christians who are with True News I I
recognize some of those names haggy and
those guys okay oh no that's the ones
with design design they're they're
calling out but these are some of the
mainstream Christians it's very sad to
see many of these people are pushing
this uh this war propaganda
they're helping they're complicit in
what's happening and they're they're
totally off the way of who they're
supposed to be following the uh Prince
as they claim the Prince of Peace Jesus
yeah so that's uh very very very sad I
always thought it was kind of strange
that that they um they got they they
want to Buddy up with the Jewish people
who denied Jesus but they they they hate
us and we believe he's coming back and
we and we love him and could figure that
one out uh so your experience then when
you started to uh as a young boy you
would hear a lot of this propaganda you
would hear a lot of this uh and then
what what did it for you that you fin
you finally um you know light bulb went
on and you started to uh do what you
started to do more research you started
to uh go deeper into this that you
started to see the difference between
Judaism Zionism and to get a better
understanding like you do now that
opened your mind well I started asking
the rabbis questions that they
got upset with me for asking like things
about um references to Jesus in the
Torah and you know
um a virgin giving a maiden giving birth
you know a young girl giving birth to a
a savior and all the things that were in
there and they didn't like they didn't
like my questions and um right around
then when I was 14 Kennedy got killed
and I like I said I started looking
behind it took a little longer then
because we didn't have all this
high-tech stuff but we it still smelled
weird because they were they were too
quick with an answer like oh he did it
oh look at that the guy that shot him he
got killed you know everything was
happening like it was Clockwork you know
and we started getting suspicious like
this isn't what there was a conspiracy
here and we didn't have to be we didn't
need a cell phone to tell us and um that
was then I my my search started becoming
not just on the physical plane but I
started questioning my religion I
started questioning it uh because it
didn't seem
like it didn't seem like it was it was
the whole story I wasn't getting the I
was taught in Hebrew school Abraham was
the first
Jew then I learned years later there was
no such thing as a Jew until his
grandson nobody called anybody a Jew
until his Grand son came along he was
Abraham was a submitter he says so I'm a
submitter submitter we know what that
means it means I was a Muslim I
submitted my will to God's will same as
Noah we're taught in Hebrew school Jews
claim Noah and Abraham as theirs like
they're they're Jews they're not Jews
they're submitters there was no Jews
back then but that's that's how it got
that when I started realizing that I
started going
I got to get out more often I got to
look
around now you've uh said that Jesus was
a Palestinian and he was I don't know I
don't know the Geographics he was from
that general area Bethlehem he was from
Palestine that whole area Galilee I
don't know if that's Judea or pales I
think it's all Palestine it was all
called Palestine I think but I I'm not a
geographical expert forgive me but he
was definitely from that neighborhood of
the world he was from that place that
area now now now Jews they don't accept
Jesus peace be upon him a as the Messiah
because and they don't worship him as a
God and now Muslims we actually don't
believe that he is like 50% there's a
study that went out and they confirm
that almost 50% of Americans here don't
believe Jesus was God they believe I
mean this is just going with their
nature obviously because that's good
that's good yeah and I think it was 35%
Evangelical Christians so they're
actually closer to Islam that's right
because they're calling him a a
righteous teacher but now if even Jews
if they because there's like you being
from a Jewish background grew grew up a
Jewish family now this controversy what
is the belief in Judaism what do what do
Z what do people believe about Jesus
well if you talk to a Zionist you'll
have to wash your ears out after they
get done talking if you talk to these
Orthodox Jewish transplants that are
coming from Brooklyn and other places to
steal houses from the Palestinians they
they say if he comes back again we'll
crucify him we spit on them they they
they um it's a common thing in Israel
that spit on Christians and um I think
they're trying to stop that but I heard
that's a common
occurrence
and um but there's a whole spectrum of
how Jews look at Jesus depending upon
which Jews you're talking about some as
you say look at him as a righteous
teacher a rabbi
not even but not as a prophet not as you
know anything else others I wouldn't
even want to repeat it like from the
talmood the rabbi the rabinal the
Babylonian talmood writes things about
him and his mother that I wouldn't even
we don't have to repeat yeah yeah you
don't want to repeat so there's a whole
spectrum of viewpoints about Jesus for
in the eyes of the Jews there from from
respect and ver you know reverence as a
teacher and a wise you know Rabbi to the
other end of the stick but nothing in
the form of a of a leader of their
leader or their I think in part that was
the fault of the Christians who changed
the story and alienated the Jews when
they said he's God and the Jews said no
no no there no man is God you know so
the Jews reacted when the je when the
Christians started claiming Jesus as God
or as due worship that violates the
first commandment of Moses
I am the one hero Israel the Lord God is
one I you know you shall have no other
gods before you so I kind of have a
vision I can my lens is wide enough to
see why a lot of Jews rejected Jesus and
I think they'll have a chance to get it
straight because nobody ever gave it to
him straight because the Christians that
came to them were trying to convince him
convince Jews that he's God or that he's
the son of God and that he's due worship
as God would be and this is a definitely
a big no no in any monotheistic religion
so yeah um so you saying that if the the
Jews of today if they got us if they're
sincere like you true Seeker if they
really got to look at who Jesus was from
a Islamic perspective they would accept
him as the Messiah then that would bring
them closer now even to accepting the
last and final message of prophet
Muhammad that would depend upon the
individual individ I would have to say
that depends on the individual if
they're sincere if they really are only
Allah knows what's in a person's heart
exactly exactly what do you think is the
reason now when you we mention all these
things uh these really hurtful things
and these Blasphemous things that are
said about Jesus peace be upon them we
we proudly say we love we love Jesus H
but then you have it's very sad uh
unlike these Christians who are speaking
out you have you have many Christians
Zionist Christians who are going along
with this and supporting this group of
people who say the most horrendous
things about Jesus and you what it seems
it's a really ironic a strange
relationship it sure is it's
schizophrenic it is it's
crazy
going to go to jail the police here 99%
conviction R shut up we don't do
anything illegal you cannot take this to
jail if you are not involved please go
Shalom my friend we bless you you're my
country you come to United States you
can say whatever you want to say that is
a free world yes you're not in the
United States you're in Israel I
understand you cannot say whatever you
want to say here yes you can it's legal
it is legal to preach about Yeshua we
preach at Damascus gate the police said
it's okay we preach at jate the police
say it's okay please
stop
I respect you respect me doesn't have to
respect you doesn't have to
respect that is the right thing are you
Jewish do you want to honor
God that is The Godly thing to do we
respect one another The Godly thing to
do is just to kill you The Godly thing
is to kill me that's right that's what
the Torah says the Torah says to kill us
the Torah says that Idol people who
worship Idol such as yourself when there
is a
Sanhedrin to kill us yes okay that's
what the Torah say how the Jewish people
feel about Christians yes that you
discriminate against Christians
Christians are Idol discriminate against
the Tor says that Christianity is idol
worship it's not but I think they
they're they're doing that I think
because they believe that there's some
kind of a tie between well there is a
tie between Jesus peace be upon him and
the land the place because that's where
he's going to go you know he's going to
go to Jerusalem and that and that that
he's going to confront the Antichrist
the all over there and but
um it's I don't think they reject
they're afraid they're afraid I don't
think they never got the story straight
they never got the story told to them
straight all right the Muslims have the
story straight they got a bunch of
versions from the Christians because the
Christians want as
stray and they and they started telling
their astray stories and their astray
gospels which weren't the actual Gospels
El which freaked out a lot of the Jews I
think and I think a lot of Jews God
willing will see it when they see it
clearly when they see it clearly and and
a lot of the Christians will too I hope
it's not too late that's for
them uh before we conclude what other uh
uh last closing comments with everything
that's going on connecting it to your
story we hear a lot of different things
you know they make it seem like Muslims
hate Jews and this is a war between
Muslims and Jews and Muslims are savages
and you know they're trying to lump
everybody up with this uh with with
certain groups and whatnot uh what
advice do you have uh for the people
listening out there well I read
something recently it
said the purpose of propaganda is to
make your
opposition appear to be less than
human and that gives you the right to do
anything you want to them you see and
that's what they that's what they that's
what the the the zionists are doing to
the
Palestinians okay and and and that's
what every group every
oppressor does that look at you know
it's like these guys are an you know he
allowed this to happen so that he could
say look at this and this woman at the
at the kuuts is going it was the IDF
that shot us up not the Arabs you know
and but it's like is that ever going to
get to the headlines I knew a lot of
stuff about 911 but I never saw get to
the mainstream media where
people they believe it if it's on the
mainstream media it's like going to oh I
only believe it it's from a doctor I'll
only believe it I only believe it if
it's on the television no what I advise
people to do is to pray sincerely and to
use the brains God gave us and the
intuition intuition is highly underrated
you know the PE the Christians come to
me on Facebook sometime and they start
throwing chapters and verses at me and I
go you know
something the people who knew the book
best when Jesus was here peace be upon
him they missed them and the ones on the
street that probably couldn't read they
probably didn't even have a book in
their house they felt them they knew who
it was from the the love from the from
the energy from the frequency and so
what I ask everybody to do because we're
in these times where truth is covered
over it's a you know the truth is is
hard to find now days so what but we can
and what I advise everybody to do is to
ask Allah to to show us the truth inside
show us what's going on give us the eyes
to see through the veils of propaganda
and lies and darkness and if the whole
world is telling you a lie that doesn't
mean you have to believe it you know
I've been living like this since I was
14 I'm 74 years old I'm telling you it's
worth it it's worth it
it's worth it because you know what it's
nice I it's nice to know the truth
before you leave this world and it and
I'm not saying I'm Le I nobody knows
when we're leaving but it's nice to know
the truth this is this is more
incredible than any movie any sci-fi any
action adventure the reality is more
incredible than anything you could go
and watch in a flick so get into it and
this is participatory
if you see something wrong fix it with
your hands if you can if you can't speak
about it speak up Muhammad peace be upon
him said even if you know one thing I
said say it it's like so many people go
oh I don't I don't know very much it
doesn't matter you might know more one
more thing than the person that's what
homeschooling is about you pass on you
learn one thing you pass it on to the
next one you so we got to pass on what
we know to each other and keep and don't
give up on looking for the
truth trust God we're going into some
rough times right now it's going to get
worse until the until Jesus comes back
there's not going to be any any letup so
everybody like my father used to say may
Allah bless him in his grave and give
him the highest Paradise it's time to
buckle down it's time to buckle down and
to practice our faith not just in the
Bowing and the praying but in the living
and this and and the action of Our Lives
thank thank you s thank you for spending
some time with us and shedding some
light on some of these things just thank
you for having me thank you Salam alikum
AUM Salam brother God may Allah bless
you amen you too brothers and sisters
we've all had loved ones that passed
away a mother a father a brother sister
a close family member but one of the
mercies of our Dean is that with the
right intention we can go ahead and
continue to do good deeds on our loved
ones behalf and what greater of a
continuous Good Deed Sadia than
investing on their behalf in the dean
Center a mid and mega dawa Center that
will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you you're not yet Muslim and
you're tuning in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go ahead and
visit theen show.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you if you still have some
questions about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum